foreign
hi Patrick welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call
here's my question
so I've got over a quarter of a billion
in my retirement account and over the
years I've seen it go up and down
and after hearing the news about uh what
what went down this weekend you know
with the two banks in the Silicon Valley
um I'm wondering if I should take money
out of my retirement and pay off my
credit card debt that's my my major debt
is my credit card followed by my home my
my car is paid for so it's basically
those two bits that I'm working with
what do you have your money on what do
you have your money invested in
and um you know when I left the county I
had it in their retirement plan a 401
and 457. in mutual funds
correct what's that got to do with the
bank
well last time that all happened in 2008
uh I just shut the door on that book
because it looks so bad you know is it
going to fall and I'm going to see this
money diminish would it be better off to
use the assets I have now pay off my
debt and that way the money I earn is
mine I can put it in the bank and invest
it how old are you
I am going to be 60 this year I want you
to pay off your credit card debt but not
for that reason
how much credit card debt do you have
about 27
000.
yeah 23 to pay off my home
23 000 pays off your home
correct and we're we're on a good uh
Pace to do that you know I'll have that
done how much money do you have not
counting your retirement
uh
and not a whole lot you know we have
about five grand in the bank what's your
household income
about uh it fluctuates between UH 60 and
70. okay
all right and your money is currently
all in your 401k and you still work for
the county
uh no I don't oh you've already moved on
yeah about the two and a half years ago
and when you know when it started to hit
the fan I go you know what
uh I just got hit up for a position and
so I'm working part-time right now okay
all right and what do you what is your
household income today
it's about out the 66.
okay
um I would I'm with Jade I would pay off
your house and I would pay off your
credit cards if you cut up your credit
cards and if you get on a budget because
you've been really really you've been
really sloppy with money
the two good things you've done you've
done a good job paying down your
mortgage and you've done a good job uh
building up some retirement uh but your
monthly management of money is not good
it's chaotic and out of control and
you're going to end up backing credit
card debt it just because you pay them
off doesn't fix it if you don't stay
under control is that right
all right that that's the goal is to get
it all under control and and stop that
you know stop bleeding out so yeah but
the credit card debt is the symptom it's
not the problem
okay and so we you know yes we can pay
off the credit cards but they will grow
back if you don't get yourself on a
system on a budget monthly are you
married
yes and working with your wife the two
of you sitting down and we have a
spending plan where every dollar has a
name and we don't spend more than we
make because we're not in Congress
what's your yes my wife thank God has
that under control and she does a great
job for me what's your Full Nest Egg
combined
because you mentioned the 250 000 in
your retirement accounts what what other
money do you have in retirement does
your wife have money in retirement too
no not really no uh during my career she
raised the kids and stood home and you
know that that was our a way of uh I
just want to make sure that you I just
want to make sure that you working
full-time or working part-time is the
right choice right now with what you
have in retirement
right that's something I'm I'm looking
at changing you know picking up more
work maybe not with with this position
that I'm that I'm currently in but
picking up a work elsewhere because if
all you have is the 250 that's not
really uh am I going to or not it's a I
I must
that's not enough to retire on
oh right right I I got that yeah so
they're ready to retire just yet so
Patrick here's what we would tell you we
tell you to do several things and if you
don't do all of them then any one of
them might be wrong okay so number one
okay and re-engage a full-time career
number two build a budget with your
spouse that the two of you are both
participating in and get your emergency
fund built up from five thousand to
three to six months of expenses then
number three yes pulling fifty thousand
out and be a hundred percent debt free
which will help that budget and build
that savings up because now you don't
have any payments but I don't want it to
grow back and number four get out the
credit cards tonight and cut them all up
have a plastic to me okay I'm not
kidding it's not a joke no no and no uh
I've threatened to do that before okay
no I'm not threatening yeah this is you
need to change your lifetime because if
you don't you're going to end up at 65
with 200 000 and you will have forty
thousand dollars in credit card debt
because it'll grow back right no no no
it'll grow back the path I want to go
down I know I don't want you to go down
that so and then the last thing is this
um do not jump in and out of Investments
based on what you hear on the news ever
okay uh the the stock market is not
going to crash the banking system is not
going to crash this is a completely
different kind of Bank a completely
different kind of scenario than 2008 and
so I am not pulling one dime out of my
mutual funds today
or nor did I last week nor will I next
week and I'm 62. I'm older than you
and I don't have much time left yeah but
um but with the time I have I'm going to
continue to invest okay so you get you
know here it's serious stay in your
Investments quit making your moves based
on the news you can't let the the color
of the ticker tape on the news and the
music that they use denote your
investing strategy when the ticker is is
read and it says breaking news and the
music is you know and it just gets your
heart rate up and you start sweating and
you're like oh my God oh my God you
can't let that you know they don't ever
do that when it's green I know right
they don't have like happy music no they
don't breaking news it's awesome yeah
nobody does that that never happens it's
always breaking news the Market's down
and you're gonna die of a tornado if it
bleeds it leads and it leads people to
do dumb stuff and it leads them to do
things that are not good for them in the
long haul and so we've just gotta these
are the times where you lock in and if
you just hold oh by the way I gotta hit
one more thing hit
like 2008 okay let me tell you what it
is let me tell you what I did stock
market went from 13 000 to 6500 you know
how much I took out none you know what
it after that it went to 35 38 000 from
6 500. you know what a million dollars
does when it goes up from six thousand
to thirty thousand it becomes five
million dollars nobody talked about that
because I didn't get out
I rode the roller coaster so I kind of
hope it does what 2008 did okay because
I'll be getting in